c'est une conséquence inattendue de la
sécheresse les eaux du tarn sont devenus
mortel pour les chiens je m'explique la
chaleur et le faible niveau d'eau
favorise le développement d'une algue
qui a déjà tué une trentaine de chiens
en quatre ans du coup pour eux
rafraîchissements et baignades sont
évidemment interdite dans le tarn
reportage vernis gaglione franck sias
amiante la rivière coule en bas de chez
lui
alors c'est tentant de s'y rafraîchir
tous les jours sa chienne descendez se
baigner avec sa fille
jusqu'au 27 juin dernier lorsqu'elles
sont remontés à la maison ben on s'est
vite aperçu que donc il y avait sur ce
blocage blocage au niveau des yeux de la
double paupières et qui a fait donc on
est parti tout de suite chez le
vétérinaire à nyon mais moins de deux
heures après avoir bu l'eau du tarn la
chienne meurent dans des convulsions à
cause du décès c'est ça des algues des
cyanobactéries présents dans l'eau
depuis la nuit des temps mais qui
lorsqu'elle meurt libère en surface des
toxines
il ya des termes à toxines qui sont
disons donc des allergies cutanées des
pâtes aux toxines donc ils sont toxiques
pour le foie qui peuvent entraîner des
troubles digestifs et les neurotoxine
qui elles sont mortelles de toute façon
pour le chien très rapidement seuls les
chiens sont concernés quatre sont morts
cet été sur le secteur 30 en quatre ans
c'est la sécheresse faible niveau d'eau
et chaleur qui favorise la prolifération
de l'algue surtout dans des eaux
stagnantes chez l'homme
aucun trouble signaler la baignade n'est
pas interdite les touristes ne fuit pas
les gorges du tarn
ici on joue la transparence on préfère
garder les chiens sur la rive attachée
elle ajouté on recommande pas bien sur
tous les canaux et s'ils perdent leurs
chaînes sur la rivière je crois que
c'est une mauvaise image de pauvres pour
la région ah bah non s'interdit toute
façon qui longe éprouvée d'ibx de loges
pour vip la manche 1 privé de bain dans
le tarn jusqu'à ce que des orages
viennent nettoyer la rivière
mais pourquoi les toxines se concentrent
tél ici les études en cours en lozère
n'apporte pas encore d'explication mais
les cyanobactéries c'est certains
peuvent se concentrer aussi dans
d'autres rivières
m